[Music]
all right so just last week Indian
authorities captured a very suspicious
pitch you're just kind of a side ID you
don't know it's good feathers I do and I
mean we were a maniacs
those guys yeah thanks Amy but the
pigeons yeah do you guys feel like the
Animaniacs primed you to watch the
Goodfellas
I think so because when Goodfellas was
all like when I first saw it I was like
oh my god this is these are the pigeons
all I didn't think about that
I never thought that the connection
until later cuz I watched the two parts
of my life and then I was like later I
was like oh wait I see what they got
good feathers from why can't kids
cartoons be that funny now
have you watched any different kid
curtains hair unfortunately yes because
I have nieces and nephews it's you go on
Netflix and watch the original shits on
Netflix I'm like what the [ __ ] is this
it's like it's not funny isn't that
witty and it doesn't really I don't know
just well maybe I'm [ __ ] boomers [ __ ]
and it just goes over my head
course rumor this is what everyone says
but you know what I'm saying now for my
generation true what's a cartoon today
was a pretty good kid you talk about our
cars are generating good know what are
the ones now I don't like paw patrol oh
I guess so what's cool about the ones
now that I think they do really try to
help out parenting cuz in DuBois you go
to eat the carrots before you eat the
candy like they give like these little
morals and Barney
you sound like Barney yeah thanks nerd
but I'm like I hear it and I'm like oh
cool this is going in too tight that's
gonna make my job easy
all right so the Indian authorities
caught a very suspicious pigeon that
they believed to be a spy from none
other than the nation of Pakistan and if
you know anything about Pakistan India
they have years like centuries-long like
beef beef yeah and and so now there's a
pigeon in custody with the Indian
authorities hope they throw the book at
him I'm glad it wasn't a racial thing
you know like they're like I don't like
the dark pigeon oh sure no and then the
cops I see a white pigeon are more of a
grey pigeon it's actually a pull it up
he got Pakistan stamped on him I know
you tense down feathers okay
does he have a little tuxedo on I know
all right
he's organized crime pays it's pink it's
not seen something like this before
really well I mean it was it was just
like a it was like a Korean clip that I
saw were like it was like an awl it was
like a pigeon that was all colored in
pink and then there was another one that
was all colored in gold and like these
Korean citizens were just like kind of
freaking out they're like what the [ __ ]
where is our pink pigeon around and then
like people were just like watching it
and then when I was raining and then the
pinkness didn't come out of it so
they're like what the Frog like do these
pink pigeons actually like exist and it
turns out that like whoever got a hold
of these like white pigeons they just
color them whichever and then that dye
stayed on for like quite something the
step would work step would probably work
yeah I wouldn't paint works it works
then I don't know what you used to
[ __ ] stab something I wonder how the
pigeons spied on them and they know what
are you like the pigeon wasn't doing
anything like bad right it is a [ __ ]
pigeon did have a note tightly and
that's the thing so one it's a marked
pigeon seized if by the pink dot pigeons
don't actually have pink on them right
so they're saying this is Mark obviously
by a human being not a spy color man
come on yeah sure it's a little little
obvious writing a little obvious I
thought it was a communist bin he could
be and then
and then around the ankle of the pigeon
were was like a little numbered thing on
the ankles so they're like it's a code
this is the code for something and it's
trying to it's trying to come come over
to India get some information Intel and
then fly back to Pakistan it's poly just
a science experiment honestly we're
someone's pet because they track
migrations with with by tagging
certainly wouldn't that be or is it a
message because what if there's a prior
communication like when I send 17 that
means launch the missiles and then it's
at 17 on the day I'm with you how like
spy agencies are not this stupid my
question is or is it I've never seen the
Indian spy movie each other no hey you
say texting so pidgin texted a couple a
couple days later a Pakistani villager
came forward and said hey that's my
pigeon and the thing on the [ __ ]
ankle is a [ __ ] phone number have you
seen my pants and this is his litter of
hitchens oh my god so he knows why does
he have so many picture so India
captured it or India captured a
Pakistani pigeon and thought it was a
international spy which then turns out
to be just someone's pet numbers tied to
his ankle if you like its lost please
call this number I don't buy it
it's a robot vision it's like when the
guy comes pick up his pigeon they're
like so you're the spy thank you Oh
truing leader
yeah we know you're gonna take us to
your boss Turkey did you really just
crack me on my pigeon yeah he did the
baby the turkey you know they raised
pigeons right great
I had like a toilet conversation with a
with a we deliver at my restaurant and
he was straight up telling me about the
way that they trained pigeons they would
let him fly and they would follow him
with the car and they would go all the
way out to like the desert and then
they'll have a
and each time they go further and
further and that's how they race pigeons
out here they don't let them go in LA
and they'll just follow him out into the
desert Wow
yeah that's true bottom row he told me
for two hours straight we might as well
track we might as well race airplanes
and just tracked airplanes come around
LaGuardia and say hey I got the Pan Am
what do you got oh I got the Virgin I
might be let's see who lands first bet
you a grand I bet you Mike Tyson would
disagree he engines you remember he had
like pigeons yeah that that was his
beginning before he became Mike Tyson
really using a video of him coming back
like a [ __ ] be so scared of him who
did he fight who does he fight though he
says he wants to come back me um because
he's gonna do exhibition fights for
charity but man the way he's training it
looks like he's gonna come back and kill
someone like all the way he had he's
just not it's lost he's like 53 and
ripped now he's 50 years old yes at 53
70 I heard he was coming back to do
exhibition fights for charity I think so
I think it's just heart you don't think
so no cuz it's genetics like um even
since back in the day I think when he
was 13 he was already like 511 like 200
pounds like he was just that's just his
genetics didn't he win though him not a
win but he did the Olympic he wants his
boxing first and he did really well
there right yeah by the way don't you
love what a badass I am when my
enticings not here yeah my passion was
here I called Michael Tyson oh yeah no
you why didn't you taster yeah exactly
yeah well Michael or whatever you don't
want everyone whom you call gonna make
eye contact either he is the [ __ ]
greatest of all Thomas before he still
the best ever so I met the guy he
choreographed Mike Tyson's fight scene
on it man oh and he was telling me that
Mike he's like he he still moves like a
fighter and all that and he goes so he
had to basically get him to open because
you know as a fighter I was really close
super close right and then sewed on
Ian's
when they're doing the move like he's
supposed to open for camera but even his
open is still tight so there were just
all these moves and he was like he moves
fast for his age and he's like did he
punch Donnie Yen in the face on accident
I'm into Donnie Yen like fight back I
wouldn't fight back but if I'm a kid
even if I was [ __ ] Donnie Yen I
didn't know he'd be at a hospital the
weight difference along yeah he was big
in that movie I don't know man but
Donnie young - have you seen his recent
photo
easy you know how he was sick right he
was sick sick from what dude he looked
bad kleban know he was sick from
something and then he made a comeback
like he looked like he aged 30 years no
that's gently oh sorry okay I seen that
photo there Jenny look has a condition
okay nevermind but but he's okay now
oh really yeah I seen a recent interview
he was promoting wool on the Disney
movie but then obviously the promotions
for nothing now because like they're
postponing the release date but he looks
normal
he doesn't have a white hair anymore
he's like is it because he he died in
her he actually like that he'll I don't
know yeah well I mixed the two due to uh
but Donnie Yen recently has a as a photo
uh and everyone's passing that [ __ ]
around dude he's [ __ ] Rick they're
like is he really like this old like I
think he's like 60 something or fifty
something I'm like why why do these guys
that are like 20 40 years older than me
and they're still rip dude cuz they work
out you could still you can still be
that Joe by the time yeah I know what's
our excuse honestly especially with
Tyson Bart they work a harder though
that's the thing - no they just work out
dude you have more years to catch up to
them by that time Tyson or Mayweather
like cooled win in a fight right now
yeah right now play these are Mayweather
right now present-day
I think my Tyson would kill them like I
think you would right just ways to work
yeah they're not even the same way
you can't catch me weather Mayweather's
got defense I don't know because I think
with May where they're just blocking
like this you'll still die Tyson's
punches I'm obviously assuming that
Mayweather goes up to Tyson's weight
class for this but yeah that would be
funny
Tyson has to go down a little bit and
maybe maybe whether after you see a
picture of Mike Tyson right now he looks
good for someone's like 53 and he's got
salt and pepper like you care you're
just like damn that's very is just his
movement as Jerry is grandpa alive
current Mike Tyson wow he's so happy
you should see the longer he was boxing
like in his garage like yeah he's very
snappy he just started working out again
cuz he told joe rogan a year ago that he
wasn't working out anymore cuz it's too
scary like they're like the mind of a
dragon start to come out I want to own
the world but this this guy's like I
can't even turn it on cuz it's like I
think it would be to be my slaves
[ __ ] crazy that drives people to like
the Mike Tyson or the Jordan level or
whatever cuz uh what's that guy's name
that's in blackish she's like a black
comedian oh gosh uh he was chubby but he
kind of lost weight no no he's a younger
generation pretty much you talkin about
yeah but pretty much what he was saying
is so Jordan is so [ __ ] competitive
that they were hanging out and where the
playing dominoes were blackjack dominant
the playing dominoes and he was just
beating him and for the whole trip
wherever they're at every single night
Michael Jordan was not gonna be out of
play
beyond play and then he would come he
would be I would lose cuz you won't have
he had to redeem himself on a game that
doesn't even [ __ ] matter and this
sounds like take a party and then since
you couldn't beat him the whole trip for
two weeks that they were there for some
sort of press release thing he didn't
talk to him the whole time whoa
now he could finally laugh about he goes
yeah I'm so sorry I didn't talk to you
for the two weeks I'm dirty cuz I was
just pissed that I couldn't be cheap so
apparently the director at the last
dance he was going with Jordan to an Air
Jordans event and Michael it was in
Chicago and Michael challenged them to a
vet he's like hey look on the way over
here I guarantee we'll find 10 pairs of
AirDroid Michael loves the gamble he
loves to gamble and so the directors
like okay you're on and they there get
in there and like and like the guy
thinks he has Jordan by the balls
because they only kind of like four
pairs on the way there then they show up
to the event and of course everyone has
Air Jordans on because it's the two Air
Jordans event Michael didn't make the
bet without knowing that these are at
them dude some people just the pressure
of betting with Michael Jordan I'd be
like yeah sure yeah yeah whatever
and then Michael Jordan rt1 you've got a
cigar all the top athletes man they
gotta have those crazy dry that's just
insane like Mike Tyson so scared the
dragon I didn't even come pyrin anymore
because I'm so scared will happen he
told your organization hilarious you cuz
he was like jor-el's like don't you even
like jog a little bit just go to the gym
and jaw and go to see the digits and
you'll see here is either all of that
this brain goes crazy but if Mike Tyson
were here right now I'd like I think hey
Mike do Michael working you're like were
you like yellow is this all on his [ __ ]
ass so I'll definitely be all ready to
be really good that's a good impression
of you isn't it
[Music]
[Music]